il n'y a plus de rideau de fer entre les
deux allemagnes vers l'est décide
d'ouvrir totalement ses frontières pour
les candidats à l'immigration comme pour
les voyageurs des nervis nous le vrai
pouvoir en coulisses le maître dachine
abandonne officiellement ses dernières
fonctions un nouveau dauphin promu la
petite-fille de picasso récupère ses
tableaux retrouvés chez heures
restaurateurs du bas gardien de la ville
a présenté au parquet les adieux des
béruriers noirs à l'olympia le groupe
phare du rock alternatif français
dénonce l'industrie du disque
madame monsieur bonsoir le 9 novembre 89
aujourd'hui retenons bien ces dates le
mur de berlin est toujours là mais d'une
certaine manière il n'existe plus le
rideau de fer qui depuis 28 ans séparent
les deux allemagnes et comme une longue
blessure les deux europes le rideau de
fer a été aujourd'hui effacés effacée
par la pression d'un peuple sur un
régime à bout de forces
le gouvernement est-allemand annoncé ce
soir il y à moins d'une heure
l'ouverture immédiate de la frontière
interallemande pour les candidats à
l'immigration comme pour ceux qui
veulent simplement voyager à l'étranger
philippe rochot vous êtes sur place à
berlin s est ce que l'on connaît la
nouvelle à berlin quelle est la réaction
dans la rue et côté elle commence à se
répandre et on a vraiment l'impression
que c'est un symbole qui vient de tomber
depuis que les visas n'étaient plus
nécessaires pour la tchécoslovaquie il y
avait toujours la sensation que on
pouvait partir vers l'allemagne fédérale
mais seulement à travers un thé un pays
tiers
c'était comme ça qu'on a vu partir deux
cent mille personnes en quelques mois à
travers la hongrie et la tchécoslovaquie
mais là aussi on a vraiment l'impression
internat est que la frontière
interallemande va devenir une frontière
comme les autres maintenant il faudra
toujours une permission un visa de
sortie pour passer par cette frontière
est donc il faudra du temps
autrement dit autrement dit demain il
faut pas s'attendre à voir tout à coup
des queues à tous les postes frontières
soudain ruhr est ouvert aux ranimer
écoutez je ne parle pas parce qu'il faut
vous dire aussi que va se poser le
problème de l'argent qui est aussi un
véritable but
le véritable obstacle au voyage c'est
d'ailleurs aussi pour cette raison que
le mur avait été construit en 61 par
erich honecker pour redresser l'économie
de la zone communiste ou d'argent
n'avait plus de valeur c'est pour ça que
je ne pense pas que dès demain matin
l'est berlinois où les allemands vont se
précipiter pour passer le mur mais on a
été tellement surpris par les événements
de ces derniers jours que finalement il
faut s'attendre à tout ce qu'il faut
s'attendre ce soir encore philippe à une
manifestation dans la rue vers l'aise
comme on en voit pratiquement tous les
soirs maintenant écouter oui on a tous
les soirs qui se réunissent dans les
églises est donc il ya toujours une
possibilité d'exprimer son opinion et là
ce soir c'est évidemment le thème de
l'effondrement en quelque sorte du mur
de berlin qui va dominer il y peu merci
l'effondrement du mur de berlin
précisément comme tout se précipite dans
ce pays que l'on croyait à jamais figé
dans un stalinisme nostalgique il y a
trois semaines trois semaines seulement
qu'eric à necker a dû quitter le pouvoir
poussé dehors par gorbatchev et aussi
par la pression de la rue qui timidement
aux est manifestée et bien aujourd'hui
la rue dicte sa politique au régime et
face d'une certaine manière
28 ans d'histoire et d'une histoire
douloureuse
philippe lefait
je suis un berlinois disait en 1963 le
président kennedy face au mur de berlin
nous étions en pleine guerre froide
depuis les hugo repas de chef et la
carte de l'europe dessinée à yalta jeu
ni de jour en jour désormais elle est
déchirée
la décision du gouvernement est-allemand
fait exploser un peu plus la notion de
bloc de l'est
le mur de berlin édifié dans le secret
d'une nuit d'où 1961 le 13
symbole de l'affrontement est ouest
n'existe plus alors que pendant des
années pour certains il avait fallu fuir
à tout prix rempart contre le fascisme
pour les un mur de la honte pour les
autres
28 ans après son édification il va
devenir une pièce du musée de la guerre
froide
plusieurs centaines d'allemands ils sont
mort fusillé par les gardes frontières
de l'est encore au début de cette année
c'est dire le pas qui vient d'être
franchi alpha concert bonsoir vous êtes
chacun sait le spécialiste français de
l'allemagne pour le spécialiste que vous
êtes même vous avouez le vous êtes quand
même sous le choc ce soit oui parce
qu'on ne s'y attendait pas si on pouvait
s'attendre ils pouvaient être tourné le
mur par la tuerie slovaquie mais
l'ouverture même avec des visas est un
événement énorme et je crois que la
première chose qu'il faut faire c'est
s'en réjouir
nous avons assez protesté occidentaux
contre le mur pour ne pas nous réjouir
lorsqu il s'ouvre alors est ce que c'est
un signe de réaction est donc de vigueur
du régime est-allemand reprise en main
par rigoles egon krenz ou au contraire
un aveu d'impuissance complète et en
fait ils mettent la clé sous la porte
non il n'est pas là qu'est sous la porte
au contraire ils peuvent espérer voir
revenir beaucoup de gens qui partent
je n'aurais pas être à la place du maire
de berlin ouest qui va se trouver en
face d'une ruée énorme de gens même s'il
faut dix ares est déjà en république
fédérale se manifeste dès décidé d'un
quasi ras le bol devant cette arrivée
massive
on expulse lui les allemands de l'est
comme on le faisait avant on leur permet
de partir et de revenir six au nord
autrement dit vous pensez que l'exode
d'un père allemand qui pèse de plus en
plus sur l'opinion publique ouest
allemande et sur les milieux politiques
qu en fait cet exemple pourrait
paradoxalement être freinée par la
décision d'aujourd'hui
je pense que les gens qui partent au
aujourd'hui sont des gens plus
susceptibles de revenir que ceux qui
partaient il ya un mois alors trois
semaines seulement depuis le départ
d'éric à necker
est-ce que l'accélération de ces
bouleversements en allemagne de l'est
peut continuer quelle pourrait être la
prochaine étape le multipartisme selon
lui c'est à dire c'est tout le monde
s'attend à ce que le pas décisif soit
franchie à savoir qu'il ya des vraies
élections à l'assemblée avec un vrai
multipartisme c'est l'étape suivante en
principe en tout cas c'est ce que
réclament tous les soirs les fouilles
qui se réunissent en allemagne de l'est
alors parmi les mouvements qui cherche à
se faire reconnaître par le pouvoir il
ya donc le nouveau forum et est l'un de
ses dirigeants a dit aujourd'hui arrêtez
de nous parler de la réunification de
l'allemagne
mais la décision de ce soir c'est quand
même un pas énorme vers cette fameuse
question de la réunification aussi un
pas énorme vers la juxtaposition le bon
voisinage de deux états ceux qui partent
veulent aller en république fédérale
ceux qui restent on réclame la liberté
on n'a pas entendu le mot unité
allemande dans les manifestations en
allemagne de l'est et en allemagne de
l'ouest les milieux politiques l'opinion
semble beaucoup moins sensibilisés que
nous en france à cette question dans
l'unification et en dehors de l'extrême
droite
aucun parti ne réclame la réunification
pour un temps limité on ne sait pas
jusqu'à quand mais en tout cas la
juxtaposition de deux états allemands
libéraux ce qui posait pas de problème
mais je crois qu'il faut commencer par
son âge mais alfred grosser je remercie
pour cette réaction à chaud je vous
rappelle que la nouvelle est donc arrivé
sur les téléscripteurs de l' agence
france-presse
il ya tout juste 40 minutes mais
aujourd'hui déjà un nouveau signe de
cette accélération des changements en
allemagne de l'est on a annoncé que la
conférence du parti communiste
est-allemand aura lieu six mois avant la
date prévue il aura lieu dès la mi
décembre
car la réalité quotidienne en allemagne
de l'est et notamment à berlin
c'est bien sûr un pays un régime saigner
à blanc par l'exode intégralement dans
les entreprises dans les écoles
les hôpitaux ont sans cet
affaiblissement sent déjà que le pays a
du mal à fonctionner c'est ce que
philippe rochot a constaté dans
l'hôpital central de berlin est
situation alarmante à l'hôpital central
de berlin-est qui a vu partir 73
infirmières et 15 médecins en l'espace
de deux mois
nous avons perdu un seul médecin dans
notre service qui est parti pour
l'allemagne fédérale mais c'était un
excellent spécialiste des
transplantations et de la dialyse
cela signifie pour nous beaucoup plus de
travail et sa connaissance en la matière
nous manque énormément
c'est surtout chez les infirmières que
la tentation est grande
elles ont fait quatre années d'études
payés par l'état leur départ est une
perte considérable pour le pays
on écoute les nouvel ensemble on en
discute on attend de voir comment ça va
tourner mais par exemple vous voulez
rester ici oui j'aurais pu partir
définitivement à l'occasion d'un voyage
à hambourg chez ma tante mais je suis
revenu et je reviendrai encore l'année
prochaine
pour l'heure les malades comme ces
patients sous dialyse ne subissent pas
la conséquence de l'exode du personnel
médical les médecins qui reste
multiplient les heures supplémentaires
une solution comme une autre pour
compenser les départs à l'ouest vous
connaissez la décision des soldats de
l'armée du peuple vont venir ici pour
remplacer à partir du 1er décembre
les gens qui sont partis à l'ouest mais
ça ne sera que quelques médecins
le reste ce sont des techniciens comme
des plombiers des électriciens des
cuisiniers mais au moins je pourrai
employer des gens pour faire le travail
750 personnes sur 2000 employés ont
ainsi abandonné l'hôpital de berlin est
il faudra au moins cinq ans pour que
l'établissement fonctionne à nouveau
normalement
notons encore ce soir cette déclaration
officielle soviétique
une déclaration qui a été publié à
moscou avant l' annonce donc de
l'ouverture totale de la frontière
interallemande la question de la
réunification allemande
dit-on à moscou cette question pour le
moment n'est jamais qu'un exercice
purement intellectuel c'est ce qu'a
déclaré le porte-parole soviétique du
ministère des affaires étrangères pas de
réaction encore à varsovie où est arrivé
tout à l'heure le chancelier ouest
allemand helmut kohl
il va passer s'ils jouent en pologne six
jours d'une visite officielle qualifiée
d' historique puisqu'elle devrait
sceller la grande réconciliation entre
deux pays qui souffre encore des
séquelles de la dernière guerre
le chancelier avons été accueillis sous
la ville par le premier ministre est
aussi par lech walesa qui l'a reçu dès
son arrivée dans l'escarcelle du
chancelier des prêts importants qui
pourraient aller jusqu'à 10 milliards de
francs et la promesse formelle déjà
exprimé hier à bonn de ne pas remettre
en cause la frontière occidentale de la
pologne
établie en terres autrefois allemande
voilà donc ce soir pour ce dossier
allemand qui bien sûr aujourd'hui prend
un relief particulier puisque je vous le
rappelle le gouvernement de berlin est a
annoncé tout à l'heure
l'ouverture totale de la frontière entre
les deux allemagnes dans la chine
impériale lusage voulait qu'à partir
d'un certain âge le maître de l'empiré
du milieu se dissimulant derrière un
rideau rouge pour guider son dauphin est
en fait continuer à régner et bien à 85
ans
deng xiaoping perpétue la tradition il
s'est officiellement démis aujourd'hui
de ces dernières fonctions et il a promu
son dauphin le secrétaire-général du
parti gilles rabin et l'empereur et son
dauphin jim zemlin lors de la dernière
apparition publique et télévisée du
numéro un chinois
ben zhang ping
son troisième dauphin en deux ans après
ruia aux banques et à audience limoger
tous les deux pour excès de réformisme
l'un en janvier 87 l'autre en juin
dernier
c'est la deuxième fois en deux ans aussi
que deng xiaoping annonce son départ à
la retraite le 1er novembre 87 d'un kit
est en même temps le bureau politique du
pc chinois et le comité central il ne
gardait que cette présidence de la
commission militaire un poste clé qui en
juin dernier lui a permis d' ordonner à
l'armée de tirer sur les étudiants et
d'écraser les manifestations de
tiananmen un levier de commande si
essentiel qu'il paraît improbable que
donne l'abandonnent aujourd'hui on
pourrait dire que tex et au pic est une
sorte d'empereur vieillissant et comme
mao tsé toung assure l'essentiel de
pouvoir ce qui compte dans le pouvoir
qui le cherchent à déléguer ce pouvoir à
ceux qui émane de lui mais qu'en même
temps on est obligé de reconnaître que
des factions existent à l'intérieur de
son pouvoir il cherche à pianoter sur
ses différentes factions
mais en même temps on voit bien que ce
pas six et dans ce jeu obscur se précise
ce qui sera l'épisode de la succession
c'était difficile succession de deng
xiaoping et le destin de la chine qu'il
dirige depuis dix ans se joueront entre
ces deux images
arrestations des auteurs présumés du
cambriolage à cannes de la villa de
marina picasso les tableaux qui avait
été volé dimanche dernier ont été
retrouvés chez un restaurateur du var
rémy roche s'était bien ne les deux
gardiennes davila flores n'avait eu
aucun mal à voler les douze toiles de
maîtres dont 7 picasso les tableaux qui
ont été retrouvés cet après midi en
parfaite et pas dans notre peau d'un
restaurateur du pradet près de toulon
lui aussi arrêté et présenté ce soir au
parquet de grasse
très vite les enquêteurs avaient été
intrigués par l'absence d'effraction
tout juste un trou dans le grillage qui
ressemble trop à une manoeuvre de
diversion en outre dimanche matin vers
7h le gardien était opportunément parti
faire des courses pendant trois quarts
d'heure en laissant les chiens attachés
et sans brancher le système d'alarmé
selon ses déclarations alors qu'il
pleuvait ce week end à cannes pas de
traces d'eau de boue dans la villa que
marina picasso avait quitté pour se
rendre à megève
cela aussi seul à familier pouvait le
savoir les auteurs présumés du
cambriolage sont donc sous les verrous
ce soir reste à savoir pour qui il avait
monté le coup un picasso contre un autre
et tout le monde est ravi
le ministre de la culture l'heureux
propriétaire et les marchands de
tableaux les noces de pierrette ce très
beau période bleue de picasso pourront
sortir de france après leur mise ou lens
faire prochainement
mais nous gardons la célestine georges
les goûts
souvenez vous nous vous présentions il
ya peu de temps un tableau de picasso
hyper protégé les noces de pierrette ce
tableau devenus libres de sortir de
france se vendra aux enchères à la fin
du mois 400 millions de francs un record
mais les pertes pour le patrimoine aussi
jack lang a team négocier le droit de
sortie des noces de pierrette contre un
autre tableau de picasso de la même
fameuse période bleue la célestine un
chef-d'oeuvre historique
un thème que picasso reprendra toute sa
vie beau cadeau pour nos musées
nationaux
mais prenez vos calculettes et
considérer la faire réaliser par
monsieur ross suédois vivant à paris il
y a un an et demi ils achètent les noces
aux environs de 25 millions il va les
revendre 400 millions et le tableau
qu'il offre en échange la célestine ne
lui a coûté que 100 millions auprès du
marchand français didier imbert bénéfice
du suédois et 275 millions qui dit mieux
et que faire quand aucun de nos musées
ne peut rivaliser
si le ministre la culture interdisait la
sortie des noces de pires
les musées nationaux n'avait ni nos
directs ni la célestine et le marché de
l'art était brutalement associés et je
crois qu'on perdait sur deux plans nous
perdions une grande erreur et nous
perdions une chance au développement du
marché de l'art en somme tout le monde
est content il faut bien se rendre à
l'évidence l'art aujourd'hui c'est
surtout une question de marché
ce n'est pas l'entremetteuse célestine
qui nous contredira la grève des agents
des finances qui dure depuis plusieurs
mois est en train de s'effilocher
d'après les syndicats eux mêmes le
travail a repris dans une cinquantaine
de direction une crispation cependant
aujourd'hui les syndicats ont jugé
inacceptables les propositions du
ministère en matière de retenue pour
jour de grève
même si la reprise du travail va donc
aller en s'amplifiant les effets de la
grève perdure
jean pierre métivier et voilà ça devait
arriver elle ne sera pas demain dans les
bureaux de tabac
mieux au ministère des finances personne
ne peut dire quand débutera
officiellement la vente de cette
arlésienne de vigne on espère seulement
clôturer la campagne dans le 15 décembre
c'est la première trace laissée par la
grève des impôts la seconde c'est le
marché de l'immobilier
un peu perturbé cette grande maison vide
madame sol elle a vendu début juin du
moins elle a signé une promesse de vente
depuis elle n'a pu la concrétiser car il
manque un tout petit papier l'a22
vsphere au 20 août vers le 15 octobre et
parce que les impôts sont en grève tout
est bloqué il n'y a pas de relever
d'hypothèques de de levée d'hypothèque
qui a pas rien c'est alors moi je suis
suis bloqué complètement le papier
manquant la levée d'hypothèque elle est
quelque part dans un bureau des impôts
seulement même si on a repris le travail
on y fait un peu la grève des bras
croisés or il ya près de deux mois de
travail en retard
ce sont des milliers et des milliers de
sacs postaux de courrier en instance ce
sont des centaines de milliers de
chèques et quelquefois des millions
deux documents qui sont arrivés et
qu'ils sont pas classés je crois que
c'est effectivement un retard
considérable qu'a pris l'administration
et un retard qui sera pratiquement
impossible à récupérer dans un laps de
temps réduit
même les bijoux s'était accumulée dans
les coffres des poinçonneurs d'état pour
rattraper le retard
le ministère ouvre un crédit d'heures
supplémentaires et indique qu'il ne
retiendra que les trois quarts des jours
de grève
ouvrables sans y inclure les week-ends
ce que les syndicats jugent insuffisant
l'europe de l'est les relations
économiques et en fit g politique entre
cette europe là et la communauté
européenne
c'est l'un des thèmes développés bien
sûr à bruxelles aujourd'hui par michel
rocard
le premier ministre avec plusieurs
membres du gouvernement est allé y faire
le point de la présidence française à
mi-parcours philippe sassier échelle
rocard entouré de six ministres de leurs
collaborateurs ont passé la matinée puis
déjeuné avec jacques delors entouré lui
dédie cette commissaire européen au menu
l'état des travaux avant le sommet de
strasbourg qui se tiendra dans un mois
très exactement on a examiné aujourd'hui
les dossiers venait de la présidence
française et notamment l'union
économique et monétaire
à strasbourg on devrait s'entendre sur
la date de la conférence
intergouvernementale qui rediscutera le
traité de rome afin d'y inclure cette
union et que de mes premiers pas vers
l'union politique au cours de la
conférence de presse donnée par jacques
delors et michel rocard on a beaucoup
parlé des pays de l'est
ce ne sont pas les événements qui s'y
passe qui nous pousse à vouloir
construire rapidement l'europe a dit le
premier ministre
mais ces événements justifie notre
volonté de rapidité et c'est dans un
langage de marin qui a lancé un message
à son homologue féminin insulaires qui
traînent des pieds je maintiens que nous
souhaiterions tous voir la grande
bretagne nous rejoindre mais elle ne
peut pas se permettre de retarder tout
le train c'est le problème du
commandement des amiraux qui pilotait
les convois maritimes en temps de guerre
shalit toujours sur la vitesse du bateau
le plus lent et vient un moment où le
risque stratégique ont fait prendre à
tout le convoi s'il y avait vraiment
trop lent peut amener on a connu des cas
la décision du commandement de la flotte
de d'abandonner le navire solitaire à
son tragique destin
la polémique du foulard un peu d'huile
sur le brasier avec cette déclaration du
vice-ministre iranien des affaires
étrangères
je le cite la france provoquera la
colère et la haine des musulmans du
monde si elle empêche le port du voile
islamique à l'école fin de citation
c'était donc la déclaration aujourd'hui
du vice ministre iranien des affaires
étrangères à ferran le 19e anniversaire
de la mort du général de gaulle
pèlerinage des députés repères à
colombey aujourd'hui louis carzou 19e
anniversaire de la mort du général de
gaulle hommage traditionnel à colombey
les deux églises des députés rpr qui
centaine d'élus s'est recueilli dans le
cimetière avant de se rendre à la
boisserie l'ancienne demeure du
fondateur de la france libre
les participants ont également tenu à
rappeler l'actualité du discours du
général de gaulle notamment sur l'europe
de l'est
occupation dans le calme des chantiers
navals de l'atlantique par plusieurs
centaines d'ouvriers après la décision
de lock out total les syndicats ont
appelé les salariés à intensifier leur
lutte
hier soir après une réunion de trois
heures la direction des chantiers de
saint nazaire était toujours opposé aux
revendications salariales
trois cent cinquante gendarmes deux
hélicoptères pour amener les meurtriers
présumés
la nouvelle reconstitution du meurtre de
céline a pu se dérouler dans le calme
en juin dernier les habitants de la moto
caire s'en était violemment pris aux
avocats des deux meurtriers présumés
la reconstitution parfaitement organisés
selon les avocats de la partie civile
s'est achevée sans incident vers 13
heures
tempête en mer du nord la nuit dernière
trois morts dans la collision entre un
ferry un cargo les deux navires se sont
époumonés par un vent de force 10 à une
quarantaine de km des côtes allemandes
la même tempête a emporté une plateforme
au large de l'angleterre et cinquante et
une personnes à bord ont pu être évacués
à temps
le liban dans l'impasse politique le
président rené moawad et dimanche
dernier a commencé les consultations
pour former son gouvernement un
gouvernement dans le général chrétien
michel aoun conteste toujours la
légitimité
en outre c'est la première fois depuis
1975 qu'un président libanais est
installé dans le secteur musulman de
beyrouth
le beau temps persiste à la bourse de
paris où la séance s'est de nouveau
achevée sur un gain +0 96% dans cette
ambiance même la devise américaine
reprend des couleurs à s'y prend 25 70
l'objectif brisé l'un des vrais tabous
de notre société les moyens insuffisants
encore sans doute mais sûrement efficace
un numéro de téléphone où l'on trouvera
des gens à qui demander conseil les gens
à qui parler et puis une campagne
d'information dans les médias pour
encourager celles qui se taisent à
sortir du silence
il y a en france des millions de femmes
battues la violence conjugale et la
routine des policiers michèle andré le
secrétaire d'état aux droits de la femme
a décidé de passer à l'attaqué
le dossier and gas purger une femme
appelle au secours
urgence d'une soirée ordinaire tier que
m'a dit tu de sai tout mafia pompiers
c'est je vais descendre sisters djediat
ne touche pas tu vas y toi conte ancien
français
pourquoi ses bienfaits sont diplômés
travaillent pour eux et tout suspense
avant cela je suis pc des pompiers des
coupures ou ici dans la joue à cheval à
la civaf internet il avait frappé mais
seulement la violence conjugale qui
s'exerce dans l'univers clos du foyer de
l'humiliation du premier coup de poing
jusqu'à la destruction de l'autre puis
un soir il rentre et me dit bon bain le
week end prochain
tu te prépares et je viendrai avec
quelques copains et que qu'ils soient
consentantes ou pas il passera d'un
sursaut ce qui n'est pas supporté des ti
coat vous prenez ma fille éclatait la
tête sur ciment il y avait le sabre dans
la main il avait le pistolet et ds votre
merci une [ __ ] je vais la tuer et moi
j'étais malheureusement tant parce que
moi je l'aimé encore mon mari mais ça
m'empêchait pas plus jolie mais quand on
aime ses plus fortes et ce quoi
pour briser cette dépendance et cet
isolement ascquois télévisée vient
aujourd'hui alerté la police les
médecins les voisins qui trop souvent
préféré ignorer les victimes certaines
femmes aujourd'hui il existe un endroit
plus dangereux que nous rue mal éclairée
où un parking souterrain c'est leur
propre foyer est l'homme le plus
susceptible de les maltraiter de les
violenter n'est pas un étranger mais
leurs propres compagnons et l'homme avec
qui elles vivent
c'est parce que trop de jeunes
s'imaginent avoir tous les droits dans
leur foyer de près de deux millions de
femmes sont battues régulièrement en
france la violence conjugale
comme toute autre forme de violence est
inacceptable donc le spot que vous
pourrez voir plusieurs fois sur vos
écrans de télévision l'olympia plein à
craquer dès ce soir jusqu'à samedi et
des adieux à la fleur de l'âge les bus
rayé noir groupe de rock français et
alternatifs en ont assez du showbiz ils
ont décidé de tout arrêter
destroyed comme dirait agnès poirier et
pascal couillaud la zone la radio rodéo
les béruriers noirs tirent leur
révérence après sept ans de galère et
200 mille albums vendus ils se séparent
dans un ultime éclat de rire seuls 100
multinationales du disque sent attaché
de presse
ils sont devenus le groupe phare du rock
français indépendant
avec ce court métrage qui leur ressemble
et un dernier disque qui s'arrachent
souvent fauchées toujours marteau c'est
le titre les clowns guérilleros ce
quitte la scène c'est bien quand on
appelle à bages ça montre encore une
fois qu'on a un groupe lillois c'est là
qu'on n'a aucune pression pour pas rater
quand on le vit on voulait faire une
belle fin là on finit avec un disque qui
est très bien mais vraiment très content
qu'ils ont fini par trois concerts à
l'olympia
qui risque de s'annoncer très très chaud
les mots qu'ils ne disent pas la
latitude et l'amertume devant un
mouvement rock alternatif qui se
désagrège il y a dix ans voyant qui
n'intéressaient personne les rockeurs
français se prennent en main radios
journaux concert label de disques un
réseau parallèle indépendant et
artisanal secret autour des groupes de
rock et depuis quelques mois le paysage
a changé
longtemps sceptiques les grosses maisons
de disques les majors compagnies se
mettent à signer à tour de bras les
groupes de rock français
du côté des petits labels subitement
délaissées comme ici boucherie
productions on est plutôt amer qui reste
des petits rôles dans les carrières en
europe en france y en a plein de super
tu as encore et encore de la serre de la
foudre qui court encore à ce qu'ils font
et qui croient encore à la musique
moi non se tourner vers ces groupes là
et on va travailler avec eux
le rock métissé frénétique avait séduit
tout le monde
labels indépendants et major compagny la
mano negra n'a pas hésité ils ont quitté
boucherie productions pour une
multinationale vers jean qui leur laisse
toute liberté de création
trahison accusent leurs amis alternatif
nous sommes des musiciens réplique-t-il
pas des militants ça nous a permis que
le disque sorte dans 18 pays étrangers
ça me permet d'aller terme aux états
unis ça nous permet d'aller au japon ça
vous a un mental et en urs ça nous
permettent d'aller dans mon pays et il
est d'aller dans des pays où le 10 sera
distribuée quoi s'ils n'étaient pas
forcément possible dans un petit label
du réseau d'initier à la multinationale
pour la mano negra transfert réussi mais
combien d'autres groupes signés derrière
à la va-vite finiront dans les bacs à
soldes
ce soir-là à angers après 4 rappelle le
public ne veut toujours pas partir pour
la mano negra
c'est tout ce qui compte
chaud chaud le rock l'actualité aussi
avec l'information essentielle ce soir
je vous le rappelle on l'a appris à
19h10 très exactement le gouvernement de
l'allemagne de l'est a décidé de fêtes
de dissoudre le rideau de fer et de
rendre à peu près perméable la frontière
entre les deux allemagnes philippe
lefait pouvez tout à fait en en plus
quelques détails sur cette décision du
gouvernement est-allemand
il est dit par le porte parole du bureau
politique du parti communiste que la
police a reçu instruction de délivrer
immédiatement des visas pour les départs
définitifs sans que les conditions mises
auparavant un tel départ ait besoin
d'être réunies quant aux simples voyages
à l'étranger la permission peut
désormais être demandée sans exposé des
motifs tout ça est donc très très
important les autorisations poursuit le
porte-parole du bureau politique du
parti communiste seront délivrées
rapidement et les refus ne seront
opposés que dans des cas exceptionnels
c'est ce que poursuit le communiqué et
monsieur schabowski qui est donc et un
nouveau membre du bureau politique du
parti communiste et qui est aussi le le
porte parole du comité central du pc est
allemand précise à une question est ce
qu'on va détruire physiquement du mur de
berlin il dit pour l'instant il y as
d'autres questions qui doivent être
prises en considération il estime qu' on
peut l'envisager si dit-il la rfa donc
l'allemagne de l'ouest et l'otan
décident de prendre des mesures de
désarmement
alors pour résumer rapidement 13 août
1961 le mur de berlin aujourd'hui
symboliquement cette frontière disparaît
depuis le début de l'année depuis le 1er
janvier deux cent mille allemands de
l'est sont passés à l'ouest sans
forcément passer par cette frontière
entre les deux allemagnes c'est à dire
c'est à dire un peu plus de 10% de la
population fait donc désormais ils
peuvent passer directement de l'est à
l'ouest sans passer par la hongrie ou la
tchécoslovaquie ou la pologne
comme on a vu 7,7 que dans les
ambassades et puis il faut dire aussi et
là c'est peut-être pour résumer que ça
va très très vite
nous sommes trois semaines après le
départ de necker alors qu'aujourd'hui en
allemagne de l'est
l'équipe à la tête du pcc a été
resserrée elle été rajeuni autour d'un
réformateur plutôt réformateurs qui
s'appelle monroe qu'on parle de
l'égalisation du nouveau forum qui est
le mouvement d'opposition qu'on parle
également d'élections libres
on se résume plus de visas pour les
allemands de l'est ils peuvent partir
c'est acquis pour les familles
allemandes c'est la perspective de
réunification entre l'est et l'ouest et
pour tout les str
de l'est et de l'ouest c'est plus que
jamais l'idée qu'il faut travailler sur
la réunification des deux allemagnes
alors c'est l'information à chaud c'est
aussi l'histoire en marche
l'histoire en marche c'est ce dont
témoigne l'hebdomadaire l'express
oui voilà les deux internes express qui
va diffuser à partir de demain dans les
kiosques que son numéro 2001
longue vie donc à l'express qui depuis
grâce à françois girault et jean-jacques
servan-schreiber est l'un des piliers de
notre presse voilà pardon d'avoir un
tout petit peu rallongé ce journal
actualité oblige dans un instant jose
dans la pierre pour la météo très bonne
soirée sur antenne 2 à demain 20 heures